here are the nominees for achievement in
sound editing all is lost
Steve Boudica and Richard hymns and
Captain Phillips Oliver tongue gravity
Glenn Fremantle The Hobbit desolation of
smaug Brentford's Crist war load and
survivor
Wiley statement and the Oscar goes to
gravity
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow my heart speaking fast and Sandra's
obviously I'd like to thank appellants
are Khurram for up an amazing film
absolutely amazing film who then the
reason why I'm here is it give us such a
great opportunity and all of us Andy
bought us all together and he pushed us
and he pushed us right into the middle
of the night sometimes longer but it's
brilliant and I also like to thank my
crew obviously that they worked so hard
and David Heyman and Warner Brothers who
you know they were 100% behind us and we
couldn't have done it without that
commitment from everybody and all the
greats we had such a a team on this film
and sort of Adam big bond and I'd like
to thank everybody else on the film as
well for that so I'd like to thank my
wife Allison and my boys Danny Anna
cannoli and my crew and thank you very
very much
[Applause]
[Music]